my name is Heather Shapiro I'm a
technical advance evangelist here at
Microsoft and today we're gonna be
talking about how to convert speech to
text to sign language again my
transition but yeah and it's just an
extension and it goes through all of
your when I walk away from the mic but
for the most part it's pretty good and
there's also a way that you can if
English is not your language of choice
look at this so what are we gonna cover
today we're going to talk about just
Deaf culture in general and American
Sign Language you get a little in terms
of that and we're gonna understand some
Microsoft cognitive services
so specifically image recognition and
being felt up and then we're also gonna
look at how can we take a library of
gifts and get the text from them and
find the most similar gift using natural
language processing so we think about
Deaf culture it's important to know that
or to really to recognize that deaf
people can do anything a hearing person
can do except here so when you're
referring to the deaf community or deaf
culture capital D for deaf that means
that the person is active in Deaf
culture lowercase D means that they're
not active in Deaf culture but they
still have profound hearing loss
then there's hearing and hard-of-hearing
so these are just some terms to be aware
of when you're referring to the deaf
community and deaf culture so we're
gonna focus specifically on American
Sign Language so there's different
dialects for sign language
so there's British sign language there's
tiny sign language we're gonna focus on
ASL so you can all do a thousand times I
clicked so American sign language is the
official language used by people in the
Deaf culture in America it's an actual
language it's not a shortcut of spoken
English and there there's just no word
in form and it's not Universal because
there's different dialects in different
countries no language incorporates mime
and picture like images to express and
convey different ideas and concepts so
it's some a lot of times what you would
expect to see if you're translating from
English to sign if you're saying
something like where's the bathroom you
might say bathroom where we're also
gonna take a look at some Jupiter
notebooks and Azure
who here has worked with Jupiter
notebooks but for people who here has
heard of them who did a challenge for
the house your notebook challenge good
way to say that later that you should
all do this challenge um so as your
notebooks is in the browser and allows
you see if it's super notebooks and in
Azure and it allows you to be able to
run Python code without actually having
Python installed on your computer so you
can um do it like you use it like you
would use Jupiter notebooks except now
you don't have to have anaconda or
anything installed there's also a cool
nifty slideshow feature with it so when
I was looking to try to make this
repository or database of signing which
gifts and there aren't many data sets
out there so gift me actually has a
channel with 2,000 yes from side with
Robert so I went through and I pulled
all of these these gifts down so about
2,000
them and unfortunately the API doesn't
let you plot the tags with it so you
have to put it through OCR or image
recognition to actually find out what
what is being said so I can I'll say
hello
hmm so it's pretty easy to do that it's
just a breast call I won't go through
the code too much but we in our
cognitive service API as we have a suite
of 30 different API so vision speech
face detection there's sentiment
analysis all different types of api's
there that allow you to add smarts to
your applications and machine learning
to your apps just through a rest call
Python there were of different ones
there are different modules that you can
download as well or install that you can
use these audio services as well
for this I used the image recognition so
I put in image still that I pulled down
from one of those URLs from gippy put it
past it through OCR to try to get the
text back from it and then you couldn't
always get them because sometimes the
shading is offered if it's now to still
it had difficulties but so then I passed
it through being spellcheck
so something sometimes they would just
have random letters and things showing
up and that may give me a pretty good
data set I'll show that so pretty simple
I could just go through and say okay for
the first 500 URLs in there as a
thorough CR pass it through spell check
and the URLs and stills and then have a
table so when you at the end you'll have
using panda so you have the URLs you
have the phrase so there's alcohol dead
popcorn all different phrases that you
can use and try to find the most similar
phrases to them and then we have the URL
and distilled URLs
so what I wanted to do is try to find
the closest match how can we take this
data set of phrases and then if someone
speaks or enters the text how can we
find the closest match to that phrase so
there's some libraries that are in
Python called once fuzzy-wuzzy and the
other one is DIF lib and I'll we'll take
a look at both of them but they're
different I'm not drawing with
processing they're pretty basic but it
just looks for the most similar words
and your from your phrase to what's in
the dataset so I passed in all that to
the 2000 phrase phrases if I say like
we'll see if where's the bathroom it
will pull out the closest URL so I can't
and what are you doing and you can see
with fuzzy-wuzzy it will show you like
what are you doing is the most is the
closest hat because hat isn't here hat
again
let me see like what are you doing also
had some like weird and so there's
different ways that you can say some of
these gifts so that's why there are some
duplicates as well and then I was able
to look at all these and process okay if
I say where's bathroom pull up the gift
that matches that where's the bathroom
so common phrase that is good to know
then if we look at this lib you can see
that we get a slit even with the same
where's bathroom you get a slightly
different gift so it didn't match
exactly the same and one of the things
that I noticed when going through these
two different libraries was that the
results are slightly different one is
using the distance and the other one and
so before when we said like what are you
doing if I say where's bathroom
it's a where's bathroom is the closest
match where is the bathroom he her and
four different phrases though only he
was popping up as the closest match
because it was just pulling out one word
from there so going forward trying to
combine these two matching algorithms
trying to see if there's a better way we
can do that in what I would like to do
going forward with that but then there's
the whole speech component too so you
know switch from as your notebooks to
visual studio code and so similar to
what the translator at the bottom is
using I tried to hit that translation
API itself using using a rusty breast
call so I'm able to go in and pass let's
pick this I'm able to go in create a
wave file and I'll show it working in a
second but I passed in a wave file to
the translator API and then passing all
the headers and all the information and
when it gets that message it will look
to when I speak it will look to see okay
can we translate it to text and then it
looks to see doesn't now match some text
that's in that dataset so there you can
ignore my API keys they'll be gone and
they'll be gone soon but this is all
github as well if you want to take a
look at it after and play around with
your own keys but essentially we're
using like PI audio to be able to add
the speaker and record from the
microphone I don't save the file at all
I'm just passing it in through a
WebSocket so it's constantly when I'm
speaking I have it chunked into ten
seconds that it will record what I'm
saying and then from that it will look
I have that phrase the same phrase data
set that I had before and then I'll
create a little image showing out what
it is so I'm just matching doing exactly
what was broken down into those phases
before but now all in one piece
so hopefully let's see if the gods are
with me
where's the bathroom
so got bathroom and I can say different
things so one thing this and there's
like Groundhog Day Groundhog Day
Groundhog Day
so this is pulling all these different
api's together so we use the gifty api
which you can create a free key with the
cognitive service api is for OCR spell
check and those that are all have free
tiers as well and I'll hold that sign up
in a second so you can see and then
we're just displaying it using pilot
using sprites and having it loop so
putting it together we're able to get
speech to text to sign language gifts
and the goal going forward this is
pretty like it's not the most advanced
model yet of natural language processing
but how can we pass these together how
can we parse all the libraries or gifts
together to be able to make a sentence
if I say something what day is it what
day is it see what it comes up so
because it had what in it or had hat it
was able it only picks out from there so
but I think going forward this is like
huge place in accessibility where we can
continue to incorporate natural language
processing and machine learning to be
able to be more inclusive in our
presentations because if you go to many
conferences like this there aren't
always live captions there aren't always
someone there isn't always someone
signing or interpreting so just being
able to welcome a new community into so
accustomed to it would be great and it's
kind of like a chicken in the egg
because you know we don't know how many
people actually want this you can't tell
that until you obviously offer it so if
you tell people that there are five
interpreters or that it is more
accessible than people in the deaf
community might come more because
otherwise they wouldn't be able to under
they wouldn't be able to come and
actually gain as much out of it if they
didn't have that and then there's also
there I haven't seen much data
on whether or not people prefer
transcripts or sign language but if you
have both it allows just more more of an
acceptable nature and more people to be
able to engage is for me a more visual
learner so reading takes me to much less
too much time so if I can see it and
watch it happening at the same time it's
much easier for me personally there any
questions like so we look at some of the
cognitive services that we have if you
haven't taken a look at these api's
before there's all different types so
like I said there's vision speech
knowledge and language you can use these
to create like BOTS if you're interested
in having natural language processing
and language understanding you can also
do computer vision like this or computer
vision where you're trying to detect
what's in the image how happy your sad
people are how angry they are you can
get emotion and sentiment all from these
api's so you don't actually have to know
the machine learning aspect to it you
just have to call the API and there are
different ways that you can make them
custom models so there's the custom
vision model and a custom speech model
that you can add to your own
applications as well
so certain things that we covered intro
to Deaf culture how to say ASL so does
everyone know it again eh
yeah um we've been pull sign language
gift through Oh co-op through a giftie
API and then through OCR and then we can
find the most similar gifts for human
phrase using fuzzy-wuzzy and dif lip and
there's some other libraries as well
that you can use but if anyone is
interested in collaborating on this
going forward to try to combine them or
find a different way to make this more
accessible or how can we go forward with
the project and definitely open for that
and talk with anyone there's also all
this codes on github so if you go to my
github it's Heather B Shapiro and it is
speech to sign it has the repo and
you'll have all the code there so you
can you'll just need the API keys and
I'll have to update the remake of where
to get those keys but you'll be able to
run this little little app that I had
before um then there's also you can read
about Microsoft accessibility and what
we're doing at Microsoft to be more
accessible so starting with just this
PowerPoint presentation translator is a
great way to be more inclusive not only
for the deaf community but also other
languages so it can be translated into
40 different languages from my speech
then there's cognitive services they
give the API if you're interested in
going deeper into the machine learning
aspect there's Azure machine learning or
machine learning workbench that you can
create your own models then there's also
channel 9 and MVA feel free to email me
each Shapiro at Microsoft comm or
Twitter its micro Heather and
if you have any questions we can take a
few minutes for that it left a few
minutes extra but also if you're
interested I'll get to the question
that's like um there's an azure notebook
challenge that we're doing and if you go
to this link and complete the steps it
takes maybe five minutes at most
you can come show us and you'll be
entered to win a Bose headset or a GoPro
so it's pretty cool prize but question
yeah so on PowerPoint it's only on
Windows right now is that your question
yeah so um hopefully soon it'll be out
on Macs but right now it's only windows
plugin
um but I think that part that's the
longest the translator API is very much
in preview so there's not a lot of
documentation there which I will now add
to because I found through that and then
it's very early stages so that took the
most time the rest of it didn't take too
long who's more just formatting the API
call and then figuring out five months
I've never done that before going from
that order it was a struggle but I like
this one better
yep so the translator API allows you to
speak in any language and it will
translate it to whatever language you
say so right now I just have it say
English to English but I could speak in
Spanish and have it translate to English
and then go to the sign language gifts
it might not be as accurate just because
of the translating part but then that's
why we're finding the nearest phrase or
the closest phrase so if it's slightly
off it should be
so if you go to github.com slash Heather
B Shapiro it its speech to fine language
if and this has the ipython notebook or
Jupiter notebook it has that CSV with
all the phrases so you don't have to
actually create a giftie API you can
just pull that CSV and then it has that
this test give PI dot pi is the pilot
application so you just have to replace
the API key translated sure but if you
have any questions please let me know
about that if you have wanna collaborate
like I said this is definitely a passion
of mine I'm trying to learn sign
language
so that I can find my presentations
going forward but I am in no way ready
for that yet passion project
[Applause]